well certainly the
idea of israeli raids in the occupied
west bank is something that takes place
on a very regular basis but not usually
ending in this level of of violence and
death what we know from the israeli
military is that they began
their operation
in the north of the west bank in and
around jeanine there were several
arrests that took place but in one
village the village of burkin there was
a gun battle that eventuated in the
death of at least one palestinian man a
22 year old
the governor of janine saying that two
people two palestinians were killed uh
during the course of that gun fight and
then later in the early hours of sunday
there was
the separate operation around the
village of uh burke of bido
and in that
three palestinians were killed uh the
israelis say that they were seeking out
a hamas terror cell that was in
the process of plotting an attack
inside israel there's the reports coming
through army radio and in that second
gun fight there was a senior hamas
figure killed ahmad zaran who had been
on the run for some time and had been
hunted by israeli forces for some time
the israelis say that this was an
operation they'd been carrying out for
some days
at least if not weeks so there had been
some kind of lead up to this
as far as hamas is concerned it is
saying that the blood of its martyrs as
it called them would continue to fuel
the resistance against israel it
criticized the palestinian authority for
its security cooperation with israel the
question now i think going forward is uh
how this will be uh received both in the
occupied west bank whether there could
be further violence there or indeed as
we saw with the arrests of the prisoners
recently the palestinian islamic jihad
prisoners we saw
rockets fired out of gaza in response
after those arrests so i think there
will be some attention on gaza even as
there are reports of a potential
prisoner exchange being negotiated
between hamas and the israelis this
obviously will be a point of tension
these these deaths overnight